Once upon a time, TV shows weren't allowed
to even show married couples sleeping in the
same bed.
Nowadays?
You can't go five minutes without seeing a
love scene on TV.
But while some love scenes are truly hot,
others just amp the cringe factor up to a
million.
Here's a look at the most awkward on-screen
love scenes in TV.
Cougar Town
If you're going to call a show Cougar Town,
you need to have some cougars in it.
Still, even though actor Dan Byrd is only
six years younger than star Busy Phillips
in real life, this tryst felt really creepy.
That's because his character is the son of
her character's best friend, played by Courtney
Cox — who walks in on them together in the
shower.
Ah.. that's just gross.
Friends
Cox has been on the other side of an awkward
love scene, too.
On Friends, she played Monica, who in a sixth
season episode set out to prove that being
sick isn't going to stop her from having a
good time.
She aggressively attempts to seduce her reluctant
boyfriend Chandler, finally getting her way
by using that age old aphrodisiac — Vick's
Vapo Rub.
Oh Yea….
"Okay.
If you really want to have it."
"Oh!"
"Worked like a charm!"
Ah..
Nope.
That '70s Show
Walking in on your parents is a classic sitcom
joke these days.
In That 70's Show, for instance, Eric comes
home when he shouldn't have and walks right
into his parents' room while they're going
at it like a couple of teenage rabbits.
Viewers don't see Kitty and Red in the buff,
as the scene unfolds entirely in the form
of Eric's horrified and confused face.
Two and a Half Men
Charlie seemed to be the brother who got the
fun and glamorous adult fun times on Two and
a Half Men, while Alan got the difficult ones.
Like the time he ate just a few too many oysters
right as he and girlfriend Lyndsey were about
to get it on during a romantic hotel getaway.
Talk about a mood killer.
"You don't want to hear what's about to happen!"
It's not just real love that can go horribly
wrong — love over the Internet can glitch
out, too.
Just ask Big Bang Theory's Leonard, who attempted
to use his best seductive voice during an
erotic FaceTime with his girlfriend in India.
One problem: her parents were in the room
offscreen and heard every bit of it.
Whoops!
Felicity
The college-set series Felicity was about
a bunch of young adults trying their hardest
to grow up — and often failing.
In the first season, the virginal Felicity
returns to school after winter break and tells
her sort-of-boyfriend Noel that she thinks
they should make love for the first time.
Leading up to the big night, Felicity gets
very type A, responsible, and practical about
the whole thing, which includes buying books
about love and determining the right form
of birth control.
But when it actually happens, it doesn't quite
happen, thanks to one very poorly placed candle.
Seinfeld
In a classic episode of Seinfeld, Jerry brags
that Elaine never had to fake it with him—to
which she responds that, well, she did.
Jerry begs her for 30 minutes to prove himself,
which she declines because it will "ruin the
friendship."
When Jerry continues moping, she then changes
her mind for the sake of saving their friendship.
It concludes with a shot of Jerry and Elaine
lying in bed, with Elaine reading a magazine
and Jerry looking crushed.
Oh well.
How I Met Your Mother
On the hit series How I Met Your Mother, Barney's
brother points out the many similarities between
Barney's new girlfriend Nora and their mom.
The thought gets into Barney's head, too,
and before long he keeps seeing his mother
when he looks at Nora.
Nora eventually initiates things with Barney
on the couch — but he, and the audience,
sees Mom lying on top of him.
There's really only one appropriate reaction
to that...
"No!
God!
No God Please no.
No!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!